yeah but while we were waiting for the
hot dog crust i do have a story go on uh
that finishes the uh the lasagna arc the
the lasagna story arc well it's not eve
it's not even like a it's like a side
story now yeah yeah so after our
housewarming party
um you know we we got a pretty merry and
there was one thing i had forgotten
about japan because in my previous place
i lived on like a high enough floor that
i didn't need to worry about bugs or
wildlife or that kind of thing because
uh because you know nothing could ever
reach yeah reach the top floor of my
apartment at the time
so i forgot that uh japan has
cockroaches
right i sure do guys
most countries i had completely
forgotten that japan had cockroaches
right and
what we found out was uh during the
party we didn't close one of like our
windows fully so the window was slightly
ajar and we had left the food out
because um unlike in thailand where we
were taught to you know clean up
everything every day because cockroaches
can come
living in a house we had forgotten that
cockroaches can come because we are
living on the bottom floor yeah where a
lot of cockroaches are unfortunately i
mean it's a pretty new house so we
didn't have any we didn't have to worry
about that before um and i didn't notice
this or i didn't know this
until me and sydney were having dinner
the next day you know we kicked a nice
meal because sydney had kicked a nice
meal um and we were enjoying this curry
that she had cooked and we were like
chowing down
um and then i look over and in the
corner of my eye i see a black speck
move about right
and i and i move over and i look over
and there's a fat [ __ ] cockroach
how fat are we talking it's it's it's
about it's about that size okay that's
pretty easy that's a decent size it's
it's a it's a decent it's a decent-sized
cotton crush moved in yeah i i had just
moved in and i literally got my i i got
ptsd because if if if you don't remember
i had had a previous experience with a
cockroach in thailand a famous cockroach
yeah if uh if you want to check that out
there's a clip where i tell the story
but i i had had a previous experience
with thailand in thailand with a
cockroach um and it wasn't a pleasant
experience at all right and i remember
seeing this cockroach and sydney was
like see sydney was like chatting away
to me and uh she was like gone
gone and i just like i was just silent i
was just staring at this cockroach
and then she she like starts getting
angry go on listen to me and before and
she says that and then she looks over
and then we're just both staring in
silence and then and then it's as if the
cockroach knew that we were looking at
it it was it was it was flexing because
we lo as soon as sydney looks over it
just crawls away into the air
conditioning in one of the holes and it
just disappears
and we and me and sydney are just like
[ __ ]
how do we burn this entire house down we
can't burn this entire house down we
just [ __ ] moved into this place right
the cockroach literally did an
understandable habit
discovery and me and sydney were just
sitting here in silence we were like war
veterans right because we were just like
we we we literally escaped again yeah we
literally escaped this country uh we
literally escaped thailand so we didn't
have to experience this again yeah and
here we are moved into our new place
where it's we've been here for like a
month and we have a single cockroach in
our house
[ __ ] what do we do so um so we sit there
for about an hour being like
well do we move out again um is is that
a viable option like how how what does
the contract say right and then
eventually i'm just like i started going
on amazon and i buy like every cockroach
related
um products i can find
like cockroach traps cockroach sprays
even though i've had previous experience
with cockroach phrase i started really
never works i start reading
some of the [ __ ] are built like brick
[ __ ] yeah you could put the whole thing
if terraformers have taught us anything
that [ __ ] don't work yeah they are
invincible yeah so like i started doing
research about japanese cockroaches and
you know if sprays actually work or if
traps actually works because um
my experience with cockroaches in
thailand is that sprays don't work at
[ __ ] all and uh it can actually make
the situation worse
um and just like scream yeah they just
they just scream they're gonna happen
yeah and so that was so i order
everything and i just try to forget
about the cockroach but like but like
that night me and sydney slept with like
one eye open like we could we couldn't
sleep that night because we were just
like how can we sleep knowing that there
is a [ __ ] cockroach
downstairs you know what what happens if
i go to the toilet and i see it or i
just hear it scuffling about you know
like so dark yeah so in the dark so
so uh we finally go to sleep and then
first thing in the morning i go
downstairs to go to my office because my
office is on the bottom floor and my
living room dining room is on the second
floor
um and i go downstairs and what do i see
it's the [ __ ] it's right in the center
of my living room it's got a lot of
balls it has got a lot of balls and like
right on the kitchen and i [ __ ]
freeze up i'm just like [ __ ]
how do i get rid of this cockroach what
would i do now i don't have my spray i
don't like i don't know i'm kind of
scared that it's just gonna like run off
maybe it's gonna fly and like like me in
the face again like maybe it's gonna be
my assembly experience to what happened
in thailand i'm getting out the shoes
yeah yeah
i'm getting it yeah and i and i'm just
like and i'm having a spirit yeah i'm
like i'm like looking around what do i
do do i do i try and kill it do i chase
it away what do i do and then i like
trying to like ninja my way down right
and as soon as i try to do that it sees
me and then it starts running right it
starts running and then i look at it and
i realize wait a minute this is it's
running so [ __ ] slowly because my my
experience was with thailand cockroaches
is that like they're like [ __ ] sonic
they're like [ __ ] like speedy
[ __ ] this cockroach is running
at full speed and it was just running
like this
and i'm like and and then and then i
like i corner it so it runs the other
way because i'm still afraid that he can
fly and i chase it towards the stairs
right and i assume that it's just gonna
get to the stairs and fly off it it goes
to the edge of the stairs right and this
stupid [ __ ] right it it tries to
go on the side of the stairs and it just
drops right it just drops right and i'm
just like wait a minute these [ __ ]
can't fly
they can't fly and they're slow as [ __ ]
and then suddenly i'm like i'm starting
to feel myself i'm like all right all
right maybe i got a chance here maybe i
don't need the cockroach spray i can get
rid of this by myself so eventually like
this the cockroach right now is on the
bottom floor so it's like it just it's
it's not even flying it didn't even like
fly down it just like it just walked to
the edge of the stairs stumbled down
like landed on his back
like uh went downstairs and they kept
going downstairs so
i run down the stairs and i go into my
office and i try to grab the closest
thing i could find to like [ __ ] slam
this thing right and so by the closest
thing i could find in this rush happened
to be
a mouse pad
a booby mouse pad right
what is that gonna do why i don't you
literally could have got anything else i
think your fist would have been more of
like okay because i did i didn't i
didn't want to i didn't want to like i
didn't want to stain myself okay so
stay in the booby mouth yeah yeah okay
we used to crying right it was the it
was the fastest thing i could find in
the rush
this thing you could find did you just
have booby mouse like on because i was
looking for something like a shoe or
something but everything in my office
like i can't i can't grab it is it in
your office right next to where you keep
your shoes
um so my shoes were like in the cupboard
right so about the slam dunk shoes
usually
i am not going to use my [ __ ] slabs
so like most of the things in my office
like figures or most of the things i
could see like figures or like glass or
like like solid [ __ ] so the only thing
that was like i felt that you know was
close the closest nasty city yeah
elasticity the best thing i could like
slam this thing without having to worry
about it breaking happened to be the
booby mousepad right wrong with you guys
why was that i wasn't thinking okay
there's nothing else in your room is
this a domestic girlfriend one that you
got yeah oh no
okay so this is my [ __ ] signed piece
of memorabilia it wasn't signed it
wasn't signed i have my signed piece of
memory it was the worst girl yeah yeah
so so okay so this was just like i
explained this like i thought about this
consciously no i just ran in my room
just like grabs grab this mouse pad that
was the closest thing and just ran back
out and um by instinct or maybe not by
instinct so i grabbed like the booby
side of things right
i grabbed the tit side of things right
and but like this this mouse pad it's
like you've you feel like a booty mouse
pad it's flimsy but it still has like
some weight to it right so it's not
exactly like it's i'm hitting it with
paper it has like a little bit of weight
but it's like it's like it's like
slapping someone like that i failed to
see how you you picked this up you're
like yes this is the
dancing weapons
the [ __ ] gladiator stadium like dawns
you may choose a weapon of your choice
picks up a rock
picks up the booby mouse pad i'm ready
look i had picked it up i had committed
to wear because i was scared that i
would run back out and the cockroach
would be gone right but i thankfully i
ran back out it was still there i'm like
great i [ __ ] wham it once okay well
full strength slap it doesn't do
anything yeah yeah yeah yeah you hit it
with makes it like an air cannon yeah so
so so i'm just like whammy ones didn't
work where am i twice didn't work so i'm
just like [ __ ]
like
like like
[ __ ] quentin tarantino scene honestly
it was it was like you know it was like
a scene from a gangster movie or
something he said like i don't have a
hammer i'm not bashing someone's head in
i'm bashing this [ __ ] cockroach in
with like with a movie booby mouse pad
and like this thing okay so i hit it
it it like falls over runs back again uh
flips over runs back again but like
after after about after about five slams
it starts slowing down this thing was
like [ __ ] boss battle yeah and it had
like a [ __ ] health bar right but like
i could see his health bar like he
switched things out right so he's like
gone what's going on god i don't say
anything i need to concentrate on kiki
all i hear is the bottom of these all i
hear is the [ __ ] dark souls boss
battle music i like i like i go for it
for another like three times it's like
it's like crawling now but i still can't
i still can't do the finishing like the
i can't i still can't deal the finishing
blow so i'm just like finally after it
starts crawling i start using my head
i'm like wait a minute this isn't the
heavy side i thought you made like
literally light
what's harder than a movie mouse yeah
i was like wait a minute this isn't the
heavy side so i'm like all right i'm
going to do the finishing move i turn
the mouse back over so it's booby side
up that's this is where all the weight
is right i go for one more [ __ ] wham
direct hit one hit kill it is dead right
it is
he literally went from like
he went from dual blade to a broadside i
don't know if you're framing this story
like some kind of victory this sounds
like the most pathetic thing i've ever
heard
because
when it's like when i saw it belly up
right i literally was like panting right
that's the soft spot
i was like
ah sydney runs down right she's like
panicking because she thought i just
fell down the [ __ ] stairs or
something because she all she heard was
like wham wham i mean just like heavy
breathing and
all sydney witnesses it's just me
standing over the standing over the dead
corpse of this cockroach with like a
booby mouse pad in her in hand and i'm
just like
in my mind i was like do you see what
you get
do you see what you get
so like that that's how i felt i've
never felt so much adrenaline
i just want to know why was the
cockroach like
i don't think i've ever said like heard
of a cockroach be that i've seen maybe
he hates so much lasagna oh there are
some slow cockroaches
well i mean you probably have more huh
that means you probably have more no i
mean we already saw one and we've only
seen it all you only saw one but you
know these sneaky [ __ ] they've
probably created a club
we've got we've got a load of traps out
just in case you know and uh i've been
dealing with a pest of my own what that
sounds like i was gonna say like
yeah
um
[ __ ] pigeons keep [ __ ] on my
balcony
i'll literally i'll clean it all up
right it'll take like 30 minutes to
clean all this [ __ ] up there's so much
crap the only place actually that i get
pigeons is the window in my office which
is like on the edge of the building i
think because there's like it my balcony
is like in wood so it's like there's no
like wind or anything right i think it's
like nice and cozy for them because they
always go for like the corner top like
they nestle in a corner ah yeah yeah
yeah and they they [ __ ] on this thing
relentlessly i'll literally clean it and
i'll come back the next day and i'll be
like 15 poops
and it's it's annoying because it's like
solidifying you need to have something
to like like anti-pigeon so now i've
started having to i've gone through like
every method in the book i've got like
reflective [ __ ] all over my balcony now
right right it's just hanging up cds
like yeah stuff that reflects in so far
so far it's working no poop oh that's
good so i'm hoping that i don't get any
more poop god just remembering that
story is just getting yaggy man sorry
i didn't realize how relentless these
pigeons could be right and they're so
noisy too yeah i'll be sleeping i got my
ptsd i'll hit them
and i'm like
[ __ ] don't get out of here damn kids
pulls out the
shotgun off my load i get god's m16 from
the the
figure episode
who wants some freedom
yeah i didn't use the m16 on the the
cockroach the m16 is here oh you should
take it out
if we ever get a cockroach
up
yeah m16 resting on his uh his shoulder
i dare you i dare you to take another
bite of lasagna cockroach i dare you no
no because because after after uh after
we uh killed it or after i killed it you
know
yeah
this is not a wee thing
after our victory after right after i
killed it you know after i successfully
like slayed this [ __ ] demon
then like she fought here like [ __ ]
lisa
sweep it away right yeah so i take it
outside lay it out turns out the boss
had like a second had like a second
phase it [ __ ] gets up again right the
undead phase
the old classic played yeah the old
classic it's so weird because like when
we were sweeping in no movement [ __ ]
dead as soon as it goes outside that's a
pro right there as soon as it goes
outside turns over starts scuttling away
so i had to like [ __ ] hit it again
hit it again with what huh with the
broom or with the broom right but if
it's outside then just leave it right
you know no it's it's not it's not about
it's about sending it's about sending a
message you need to send a message
the kids are watching yeah yeah
yeah but then eventually i'm just like
[ __ ] it you know i'm gonna let this one
go i'd be like tell your friends tell
your friends what happens if you enter
this house you know
come again
come again and that's how gantt became a
local hero yeah exactly